DAN: SO RICK I WATCH YOUR SHOW
RELIGIOUSLY I DON'T THINK I'VE
EVER MISSED AN EPISODE YOU BUY
AN SELL ASSETTING AND IT HAS
YOUR LIVELIHOOD A LOT OF THEM ON
SLIM MARGINS THAT'S WHY YOU'RE A
GOOD NEGOTIATOR HAS THIS CREEPED
INTO YOUR SHOP YOU KNOW COMIC
BOOK, GOLD ASSETS HOW'S IT
WORKING FOR YOU?
>> EVERYTHING I CAN'T GET
INVENTORY IT IS SO BAD YOU ROLL
INTO A ROLEX STORE IN THE MALL
AND THEY HAVE NO ROLEX EVERYBODY
IS AFRAID OF THE PRICES GOING UP
MORE IT IS A SNOWBALL EFFECT AND
YOU KNOW WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
KEEPS PRINTING MONEY IT BASIC
ECONOMICS YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
LOT OF INFLATION.
DAN: YEAH.
YEAH I COLLECT RARE COMIC BOOKS
AND I BUY GOLD BARS TOO.
AND THE PRICES ARE THROUGH THE
ROOF.
RICK QUICK FOLLOW-UP FOR YOU
LISTEN I'M A HOARDER I'M KIND OF
EMBARRASSED TO I IS A I THROW
NOTHING OUT I HAVE A REPORT CARD
FROM SECOND GRADE I'M NOT SURE
THAT'S WORTH MONEY IN YOUR SHOP
RICK BUT ANY TIPS FOR US NEWBIES
HERE ON IF SOMETHING AROUND THE
HOUSE IS VALUABLE OR JUST SOME
COUNTERFEIT PIECE OF JUNK IN YOU
KNOW RIGHT AWAY I WATCH YOUR
SHOW YOU SEEM TO KNOW OR EXPERTS
THAT KNOW PRETTY QUICK.
>> FIRST OFF WE ALL HAVE LIKE
THE INFORMATION BOX YOU KNOW
CALLED INTERNET YOU DO A LOT OF
RESEARCH, AND AS FAR AS TELLING
IF STUFF IS FAKE OR REAL AND
FAKE YOU KNOW JUST --
IF YOU HAVE A ROLEX OR JUST
ABOUT ANYTHING LIKE THAT IT IS
AMAZING QUALITY IF IT IS NOT
PROBABLY FAKE.
DAN: YEAH.
GOLDEN RULE OF THUMB RIGHT IF IT
LOOKS LIKE CRAP IT IS PROBABLY
CRAP.
IS THAT --
CAN I --
IS THAT THE RULE?
>> GENERALLY THAT'S --
GENERALLY THAT'S THE CASE.
BUT IN SOME CASES, IT IS THE
COMPLETE OPPOSITE.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN: HEY RICK THANKS A LOT FOR
YOUR TIME E REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU COMING ON TODAY I LOVE THE
SHOW YOU DO A GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU.
>> THANKS